Blandón Ucrania ya quedó algo relegado
en el orden del día de este foro
económico mundial ahora es la economía y
el cambio climático a los que se llevan
todas las miradas pues la visita para
destacar la visita de greta thunberg que
está activista sueca quien estuvo acá
pidiéndoles a las petroleras que cesen
sus actividades de extracción quien
lideró el panel fue el propio presidente
de la agencia internacional de energía
virol quien aseguró que debe hacerse una
transición que tenga en cuenta a todas
las partes interesadas y que garantice
que no habrá una crisis energética
mundial También hubo un panel liderado
por Christine lagarto de la presidenta
del Banco Central europeo quien aseguró
que van a seguir subiendo las tasas de
interés al menos hasta que la inflación
se devuelva al 2% desde el 9% actual
también dijo que este año no va a ser
brillante para la economía pero que sí
es mejor de lo que esperaban finalmente
para destacar la visita de kire sterner
el líder de la oposición en Reino Unido
quien aseguró que partido laborista
llega a ganar las próximas elecciones no
van a apoyar la industria extractivista